also ganz ehrlich du tust so als ob ich
immer wenn ich sage dir wie immer ich
gehe jetzt rein was nichts gutes
vom geschmack her finde ich könnte das
auch eine zitronen torte mit baiser
haube sein und das geht schon ein
bisschen richtung also vom von fillinger
[Musik]
hallo zu sammeln wir machen heute einen
rhabarberkuchen ich habe in all den
sechs jahren sich ein rhabarber rezeptor
vom kanal das müssen wir heute ändern
und ich habe auf instagram gefragt was
er denn gerne sehen möchte es wird eine
richtig saftiger rhabarber rührteig mit
einer leckeren buffet haube und ich
würde mal sagen wir starten jetzt
einfach direkt wir machen einen kleinen
mini exkurs also die basics zum
rhabarber denn ich stand mit meiner
freundin lina im supermarkt gekauft und
habe mir gedacht weiß man eigentlich
jetzt so wand ist er aber eigentlich
reif dabei könnt ihr grün und rot kaufen
zwei beispiele also schmeckt halt wenn
er grün ist säuerlicher als wenn er gut
ist wenn das fruchtfleisch stammt auch
noch rot ist dann ist da eigentlich sehr
mild und perfekt zum backen um den
rabatt vorzubereiten wird er erst mal
gewaschen und dann geschält
[Musik]
die enden von rhabarber werden jetzt
einfach abgeschnitten und dann müssen
wir die schale entfernen einfach mit
einem messer hier oben einmal einritzen
und dann runter ziehen wichtig ist dass
wir dieses faserige und die äußere hülle
entfernen weil erstens ist das kein
schönes und gefügt und zwar ins schmeckt
es auch ganz es schmeckt einfach bitter
und säuerlich so hier vorne die enden
auch abschneiden das brauchen wir auch
nicht und im nächsten schritt wird dann
der geschälte rhabarber in grobe stücke
geschnitten
[Musik]
falls ihr mal zu viel rabatt und ein
bisschen was eintreten möchte dann gebt
ihr das am besten einfach erstmal so in
den gefrierschrank lasst es so für eine
stunde einfrieren und und hart werden
damit sie später nicht aneinander pappen
und anschließend dann einfach hin so
eine frischhaltedosen den deckel drauf
machen und dann hält es auch bis zu
einem jahr so aber wir verarbeiten da er
direkt weiter daher gebe ich jetzt
einmal die kleinen stücke ich habe mich
schon relativ klein gemacht gebe ich
jetzt hier in eine schüssel und gebt da
gleich auch noch ein bisschen zucker mit
dazu denn also rhabarber ist schon
wirklich relativ säuerlichen geschmack
und ich finde immer wenn man das
passende rezept dazu hat dann schmeckt
aber ich habe auf instagram gesehen
viele angeschrieben habe aber ist nicht
so meins da war doch mal ein rezept auf
raus wurde da war dann auch wirklich
schmeckt und auch mal heute
[Musik]
der rhabarber ist jetzt vorbereitet und
wir machen den saftigen rührteig ich
nehme jetzt ziehen eine küchenmaschine
ihr könnt ihr immer auch ein
handrührgerät verwenden dauert es ein
bisschen länger und sie zu aller erst
mal werden zuallererst mal die eier
getrennt wir brauchen nämlich viel
eiweiß für die bg haube wollen das
eigelb aber nicht verschwenden und
eigelb macht ja auch den teig noch mal
schön saftig daher hier erstmal schön
trennen ein volk kommt in den teig das
heißt ich trenne ziel nur drei eier und
die ganz genauen mengenangaben findet
ihr wie immer unten in der infobox und
sobald ihr das mit den eiern vorbereitet
habt könnt ihr dann schon mal die zimmer
warme butter zusammen mit zucker und
vanille extra in die rührschüssel geben
und dann schon mal schöne 34 minuten
lang dick cremig schlagen und dann
nacheinander nicht das weiß was ihr
getrennt haben sondern die eigelbe und
das voll einrühren am anfang verbindet
sich das nicht aber wenn ihr weiter
rückt wird dann wirklich eine schöne
homogene masse
[Musik]
so die eier butter masse ist jetzt so
wie wir brauchen jetzt die trockenen
zutaten und da habe ich ja mehlspeise
stärke und backpulver falls euch wundert
wofür brauchen jetzt strasser stärke das
macht den teig einfach noch mal so ein
bisschen luftiger ist wird so eine
mischung aus so saftiger rührteig aber
dennoch so diese diese leichte
wirklichkeit kann ich euch dann im
endergebnis am besten zeigen
sondern liebe ich das einfach dazu das
wird ein ganz kurz untergerührt es kann
sein dadurch dass wir jetzt viele
trockene zutaten haben und nicht viel
eier butter maske dass das mit einem
bisschen milch noch mal dass da ein
bisschen nachgeholfen werden muss wenn
sie sich das dazu und während ich kurz
umrühren bei niedriger stufe durch
einfach ein bisschen milch mit dazu
damit das eine richtig schöne homogene
masse wird
[Musik]
jetzt mache ich mir meinen tortenring
ihr könnt auch eine springform nehmen
und stellt den einer 24 zentimeter und
ihr seht ihr in meinen videos ganz oft
dass ich meinen tortenring einschlage in
backpapier das mache ich wenn teig
relativ flüssig ist aber in dem fall ist
der teig nicht flüssig der ist sogar
relativ fest erinnert mich ein bisschen
an muffin teig und da gebe ich jetzt
einfach fast alles also ich würd sagen
drei viertel
hier reingeht dann rhabarber um drauf
ich streiche es natürlich schön bleibt
und dann kommt noch mal so ein bisschen
was den teig oben drüber und wird dann
im vorgeheizten ofen vorgebacken
vorgeheizt auf 180 grad ober und
unterhitze und da wird er dann erst mal
für 30 minuten gebacken und dann zeige
ich euch wie es mit dem bc weitergeht
[Musik]
der rhabarber wird übrigens so ein
bisschen wasser gelassen haben und
deswegen einfach hier das wasser
wegschütten und dann erst oben drüber
verteilt
[Musik]
so kurz vor ende der backzeit also circa
10 minuten vorher könnte die bse hast du
schon mal vorbereiten und da nehme ich
jetzt einfach das übrig gebliebene weiß
dass ihn so sehr dass es uns ja extra
beiseite gelegt haben gebe ich jetzt
ziehen die küchenmaschine und dann fange
ich erst mal an 30 sekunden lang schon
mal ein bisschen an zu schlagen und dann
gebe ich einfach zur mediation dass du
weg einfach dass die baiser masse
richtig schön festwirt und ganz zum
schluss könnte noch einen spritzer
zitronensaft dazugeben auch nochmal für
die festigkeit und dass das ganze fülle
ich mir dann entweder in einen
spritzbeutel um oder ihr macht das
einfach so mit einem teig sauber ganz
und regelmäßig aber dass zeitgleich noch
wenig kuchen aus dem open kommt
[Musik]
und jetzt den backofen runterstellen auf
150 grad dann allerdings bei umluft so
bei mir war der jetzt übrigens circa 33
minuten im backofen einfach darauf
geachtet dass es oben schon leicht
goldbraun geht ihnen brauchte er gleich
noch einen moment ich habe jetzt meine
bitterste doch in einen spritzbeutel mit
lochte umgefüllt und jetzt muss wirklich
schnell gehen damit es auch nicht
schmelz daher schnell wie gesagt einfach
nur das muster eurer wahl drauf spritzen
ich mache das jetzt einfach so kreisrund
von innen nach außen wird aber auch ein
regelmäßiges muster einfach ohne
spritzbeutel auch machen könnt das ist
euch weil ich konnte nicht einfach aber
ich glaube konzentriert hier auf meinen
kreis achte und ich gebe gleich noch
mandeln obendrauf einfach weil mir das
skript spontan eingefallen ist und dann
kommt das ganze zurück in den ofen
[Musik]
eine ähnliche meinung raus das ist ob
genommen so lässt sich gerade also ganz
ehrlich du tust so als ob ich sagte wie
immer ihr spiel treiben und was nichts
gutes
es ist wirklich nicht jedermanns sache
aber ich mache es zu jedermanns sache
[Musik]
also von der konsistenz her finde es
cool
ich sage euch gleich meine meinung setzt
sich aus den haben sie auch mal reden
mir schmeckt das so herzhaft süß
gleichzeitig weiß nicht wieso ich möchte
so herz noch keines meinen dass du das
eher herzhafte mit mit sauer zitronig
verwechselt meine ehrliche meinung also
ich finde es gibt keinen saftigen kuchen
graf auch als ich das hörte das hat sich
durch die schüler für die entziehen ich
es annehmen dass auch undeutlich normal
wie mein messer dadurch leitet das ist
extrem saftig vom geschmack her finde
ich könnte das auch für zitronen torte
mit bw haube sein oder also ich finde es
schmeckt einfach eine saftige zitronen
talk ich finde das geht schon bis zur
ablösung von verteidiger vom feeling her
ja von der konsistenz her geht's
richtung weich gewordene apfel aber ich
finde wirklich eheleute probiert man
macht die augen zu probiert wenn ihr die
zitronen fans seid dann ist das voller
ding wenn ihr keine zitronen fenster
durch das ist nicht jedermanns schon gut
ja aber ist dass jedermann weiß was ich
glaube dass es so für eltern
schwiegereltern ob sie für das glaube
ich
also ich glaube dir das richtig feurig
meine kurze story erfolgreichen klasse
wir waren in wochen oder drei act anlass
um ein stück kuchen ich stehe total
gebackene torten von cafés und dann hat
die hat die kellnerin radiant ein stück
kabarett orte geht aufs haus ist und
sich ganz so gelungen und ich okay aber
trotzdem
haben wir dann an leute der war komplett
roh und es war wie so eine schlimme
erfahrungen das war noch vor zwei wochen
richtig so abgetan rhabarber saison
dieses jahr bin ich froh dass ich noch
ein gemacht habe berkshire ordnung dafür
dass acht von zehn ich bin aber dafür
ist er schon ein bisschen besser
eingestuft ist lecker aber es ist keine
brille
das management hat damit dabei warte
jetzt wo man lang testen
ob das
aber habe
[Musik]